speaking of the Jews the Jews it turns
out Joe Rogan hates us mate does he yeah
apparently but the internet says Joe
Rogan's massively anti-semitic hates the
Jews yeah because he said this the idea
that Jewish people are not into money is
ridiculous listen it's like saying
Italians aren't into Pizza it's [__]
stupid listen yeah if you say that
there's any truth to the idea that Jews
Like Money you must hate the Jews mate I
think that's the only logical
explanation and Joe is is obviously a
massively hateful guy yeah I know and he
hates everyone of course he hates
actions that's why he keeps having Jews
on the show because he hates them that
much yeah and that's why he's best mates
with Irish Affair that famous non-jewish
sounded non-jewish looking comedian I
mean there is nothing Jewish about Ori
in any show you not do a show called
Jude yeah I mean he might have done mate
but you know this is you know this is
circumstantial evidence